la poudrière et le fortin de la redoute
au xviiie siècle le chef-lieu de la
colonie se développe à l'est de la
rivière saint denis la plaine située au
pied de la montagne accueille seulement
le camp des as caves du roy de cimetière
et un lazaret au su de cette plaine se
dressent les deux premiers édifices
militaires de saint denis un fortin est
une poudrière en raison de leur
caractère stratégique
ils sont isolés au milieu d'une zone où
il est interdit de bâtir transformée en
chapelle depuis les années 1990 la
poudrière de la redoute a été édifiée en
1751 l'ingénieur du roi des forges
boucher a souligné son pignon d'une très
belle corniche ses murs en basalte de
mettre 30 d'épaisseur sont flanqués sur
ses façades est et ouest de 6 puits sans
contreforts des affectés pendant près
d'un demi siècle
cet ancien magasin à poudre implantée à
l'abri d'une colline abrite aujourd'hui
un lieu de culte catholique la redoute
bourbon se trouve à quelques mètres à
peine
entourée d'un mur d'enceinte arrondies
aux angles ce fortin de défense est une
livrée en 1756 de plan carré
ces élévations rap est une pyramide dans
le sommet a été tronqué sa porte
d'entrée des cours et du blason de la
compagnie des indes les douze meurtrière
du rez-de-chaussée rappelle sa fonction
défensive
protégé au titre des monuments
historiques
tout comme la poudrière le fortin
devrait accueillir dans les années à
venir
un parcours pédagogique sur les
relations entre la réunion et les
réunionnais et l'armée